el principio de la pandemia quiero
hablar con ustedes directamente después
de haberme desplazado y haber estado con
ustedes en todas partes en el país y de
haberlo consultado ampliamente donde
estamos en este momento en el combate
contra la coidh 19 gracias al compromiso
excepcional de nuestros médicos y de su
civismo logramos controlar la epidemia y
volver a vivir nuestros esfuerzos son
proporcionados la reapertura progresiva
de mayo y junio y el despliegue de un
plan de vacunación inédito nos
permitieron obtener grandes resultados
logramos en estas últimas semanas
pasamos por debajo de las 2.000
contaminaciones
diarias en contrario de 35 mil en el
momento más alto las hospitalizaciones y
decesos está en el momento más bajo de
más de un año es decirles esto pienso
claramente en las víctimas y a sus seres
queridos
la vida a pesar de todo pudo continuar
en estos meses difíciles porque pudimos
organizarnos de manera colectiva si
pedimos mucho a los padres de los niños
a los profesores y pedimos mucho también
a los estudiantes
'francia el ampliamente pudo mantener
la situación en esta crisis unas dos
semanas
de ser para las escuelas desde marzo de
2022 dos semanas mientras que en
alemania cerraron 34 semanas muchos
pudieron retomar clases presenciales en
la universidad en estos últimos meses y
podemos estar orgullosos de esto de esta
decisión colectiva de haber hecho lo
máximo para el futuro de los niños y de
nuestra juventud este verano vamos a
acentuar nuestros esfuerzos para darle
un apoyo mayor a los estudiantes que
tengan dificultades en el plano
económico la institución de hacerlo que
tuviéramos que hacer nos permitió apoyar
el empleo y las empresas pero pudo
mantener el poder adquisitivo de los
franceses y eso está en el origen de una
recuperación
teníamos un 6% de crecimiento para el
2021 y para por segundo año consecutivo
francia fue el país más atractivo de
europa contrariamente a las previsiones
se mantuvieron los empleos y lo que
logramos en 2017 en términos de
reducción del desempleo se mantuvo se
destruyeron cerca de 300.000 empleos y
ya hemos vuelto a crear 187 mil de ellos
en el mes de mayo logramos un número de
contratos de duración determinada que
iguala nuestro récord de 2006 en la
hostelería en la cultura en el deporte
el turismo fueron los más sufrieron
muchos reconocen que los planes de apoyo
permitieron impedir dramas humanos y las
quiebras y retomar un lanzamiento seguro
para ayudar a quienes han sufrido esta
crisis a los las personas que trabajan a
los asalariados a los jóvenes a los
independent
que durante todo este periodo cayeron en
la pobreza
desafortunadamente quiero decirles esta
noche que tuvimos razón de manera
colectiva de buscar el equilibrio entre
la protección y la libertad y así
pudimos proteger la vida sin
necesariamente tener que volver a cerrar
el país esta situación controlada es el
fruto de nuestras elecciones de nuestros
esfuerzos y estas elecciones y los
resultados nos permiten abordar las
dificultades que aún tenemos frente a
nosotros con determinación porque si en
el momento en el que les habló nuestro
país se enfrenta a una retoma fuerte a
un repunte de la epidemia que toca todos
los territorios de francia metropolitana
y de los territorios de ultramar la
aparición de la variante delta se
traduce en un aumento de los contagios
en todas partes del mundo porque esta
variante es tres veces más contagiosa
que la original y se mete en todos los
lugares no están cubiertos
por la vacunación se han tomado
decisiones en españa portugal los países
bajos en algunos países han regresado
los confinamientos quienes japonés que
está a punto de organizar los juegos
olímpicos lo hará sin espectadores y si
aquí en francia la situación por el
momento está controlada si no tomamos
acciones a partir de ahora el número de
casos va a continuar aumentando
fuertemente y va a llevar a una
hospitalización aumentada a partir del
mes de agosto por eso para hacer frente
a esto tenemos que hacer algo para algo
que cambia con respecto
las situaciones anteriores que son las
vacunas las vacunas nos protegen de
manera sólida contra la variante delta y
divide por 12 su capacidad de
contaminación y evita el 90% de formas
graves de la enfermedad
la ecuación es simple entre más va con
hemos menos dejaremos espacio para que
el virus avance y más evitaremos las
hospitalizaciones y evitaremos otras
mutaciones del virus que posiblemente
serían más peligrosas por eso es una
nueva carrera de velocidad la que
estamos viviendo un es un verano de
movilización para la vacunación eso es
lo que tenemos que hacer vacunar a una
mayoría a la mayor cantidad de personas
en todas partes somos una nación grande
una nación de ciencia de las luces de
louis pasteur o entonces cuando la
ciencia nos ofrece la posibilidad de
hacerlo tenemos que utilizar estas
herramientas haciéndolo desde el punto
de vista de la razón y el progreso para
nuestra unidad tenemos que ir hacia la
vacunación de todos los franceses porque
es el único camino hacia el retorno a la
vida normal en primer lugar para las
personas para el personal de la salud
para las personas de los hospitales de
las clínicas para las personas que
tienen
condiciones físicas difíciles para
aquellos que tienen contacto con las
personas en personas de edad la
obligación será obligatoria la
vacunación sé que es difícil lo que les
pido dice que ustedes están dispuestos a
ese compromiso
y eso viene de su sentido del deber para
todos los compatriotas que tienen que
ver con eso tendrán hasta el 15 de
septiembre para hacerlo y hay que
comenzar a partir de ya mismo a partir
del 15 de septiembre se llevarán a cabo
controles y se tomarán sanciones y
después todas las otras francesas y
francesas 2 millones de ustedes que
hasta ahora no han recibido ninguna
inyección en función de la evolución de
la situación tendremos que hacernos la
pregunta de hacer la vacunación
obligatoria para todos los franceses
pero hago como la opción de la confianza
y hago un llamado a todos los ciudadanos
no vacunados a ir abajo para que vayan a
vacunarse up desde hoy 9 millones de
dosis los están esperando que no han
sido inyectadas y continúan llegando más
vacunas entonces ya sea que sea en su
lugar de trabajo cerca del lugar donde
viven hagan se vacunar es la única
manera de protegerse y de protegerse a
otros es una cuestión de responsabilidad
individual y también de essen
de un espíritu colectivo y de ahí
depende también nuestra libertad de
todos entonces pienso particularmente en
todos los ciudadanos de más de 60 años y
a las personas vulnerables como aquellos
que tienen condiciones de sobrepeso que
aún no han sido vacunados ustedes son
aquellos que llevan hoy por hoy los
peligros más grandes entonces les hago
un llamado a su movilización y vamos a
desplegar en todo en todo el verano para
trabajar con los farmaceutas y también
con las asociaciones seguiremos a
vacunar a todos aquellos que están más
lejos de los servicios de salud para
los estudiantes de colegios las campañas
de vacunación específicas se llevarán a
cabo en esas instituciones desde que
regresen las clases y finalmente para
aquellos que se vacunaron los primeros
verán cómo bajan sus inmunidades y sus
anticuerpos y quiero decirles que a
partir de septiembre se llevará a cabo
una campaña para beneficiarse de una
nueva inyección bajo las mismas
condiciones que las primeras se tomarán
en citas
desde los primeros días del mes de
septiembre entonces no hay que
preocuparse pero a pesar de la vacuna
les pido a todos ustedes que continúen
siendo prudentes y que continúen
respetando estos gestos barreras contra
los virus que ustedes ya bien conocen y
en complemento de la vacunación vamos a
tener que tomar nuevas medidas para
frenar el virus porque el nivel de
vacunación aún es muy suficiente y que
los hospitales ya están bajo mucha
presión el estado de urgencias y
sanitaria se declarará mañana en el
consejo de ministros para martinica y
reunión y se instalará un toque de queda
en el hexágono y donde tengamos tasas de
incidencia y altas y donde nuestro
enfoque será más simple
en todas partes tendremos el mismo
objetivo que es reconocer el sí mismo y
hacer llevar las restricciones a los no
vacunados en lugar que sobre todos desde
esta semana los controles en las
fronteras serán reforzadas para aquellos
que vengan de los países de riesgo con
un aislamiento obligado para las
personas no vacunadas desde el 21 de
julio el pase sanitario será extendido a
los lugares de cultura para aquellos de
más de 12 años para acceder a un
espectáculo o un parque de atracciones a
un concierto a un festival haber sido
vacunado o tener un test negativo
reciente esto está disponible en la
aplicación todos contra el co beat o
pueden tener una versión en papel a
partir del mes de agosto y eso es porque
tenemos que hacer votar una ley y
promulgar la a partir de agosto el pase
sanitario se aplicará en los cafés los
restaurantes los centros comerciales así
como los hospitales
en los lugares donde viven las personas
de la tercera edad
y en los aviones y trenes para los
viajes de larga distancia todos aquellos
que lo tengan podrán acceder a ella sea
que sean clientes o asalariados en
función de la situación nos haremos la
pregunta de la extensión del paseo
sanitario a otras actividades este otoño
los tests pcr serán pagos a no ser que
sean por prescripción médica y esto es
para
para mí
empujar la vacunación aún más
ya lo entendieron la vacunación no es
obligatoria para todos en este momento
pero vamos a extender al máximo el pase
sanitario para impulsar aún más a todos
ustedes a irse a vacunar y finalmente
continuaremos actuando para evitar la
aparición de variantes que podrían ser
incluso más peligrosos que la delta eso
pasa por un proyecto inmenso pero
indispensable y que es vacunar al mundo
francia desde marzo de 2020 ha estado la
iniciativa con el programa acta que
busca producir más vacunas y darle a los
países más pobres más dosis ya hemos
dado más de dos millones y medio de
dosis y desde aquí el fin del fin de año
daremos decenas de millones de dosis
continuaremos movilizándonos justamente
y movilizando nuestros socios para
producir más y darle más a los países
más pobres particularmente los balcanes
en áfrica y en medio oriente
muchos países hoy están fuertemente
golpeados y vamos a aumentar aún más
nuestra ayuda y pienso particularmente
en túnez para
y poner fin de manera durable a la
pandemia tenemos que vacunar en todas
partes yo lo dije el año pasado vamos a
tener que vivir con el virus será el
caso en todo este año 2021 y seguramente
durante varios meses después del año
2022 incluso si la vacuna ya ha cambiado
muchas cosas las próximas semanas serán
las de la movilización para bloquear el
virus y para continuar relanzando
nuestra economía el verano de
movilización para la vacuna será también
un estado un es un verano de retomar
nuestro plan se lleva a cabo en de
manera sostenida y peso permitido
gracias al acuerdo de la unión europea
para la movilización de 40 mil millones
de euros porque entre más rápido lo
hagamos más fácil y más rápido cerrada
está retoma entre más rápido lo hagamos
más rápido será nuestra lucha contra el
cambio climático un tercio de los
créditos se basan también en la
renovación térmica de los edificios y en
los autos de cero emisiones los
gobiernos y los alcaldes se encargarán
de la buena implementación de sus
recursos
y también haremos lo posible para
levantar las restricciones que pesan
sobre aquellas zonas que tienen las
mayores dificultades ya sea en la madera
o de semiconductores o de acero lo que
he hecho que alguien ha aumentado los
y costos también por la falta de mano de
obra una de cada dos empresas no
encuentra respuesta a estas ofertas de
empleo hay que hacer todo juntos en el
terreno para responder a esto y poder
responsabilizar a cada uno
nuestra prioridad del verano y del otoño
es poder retomar y volver a encontrar
los niveles de empleo de antes de la
pandemia sino retomar el camino del
pleno empleo si nos movilizamos para
vacunarnos para volver a lanzar la
economía entonces estaremos en medida en
septiembre de preparar nuestro futuro de
manera colectiva
tendremos que debatirlo de manera
democrática y tranquila pero también
tendremos que tomar decisiones y quiero
desde ya compartir algunas convicciones
fuertes la primera es la necesidad de
depender menos de algunos servicios de
tecnologías de otros países es la
necesidad de retomar el camino de una
independencia francesa y europea porque
hemos vivido durante esta crisis las
consecuencias de la dependencia gracias
a la acción llevada a cabo desde el 2017
estamos logrando mejorar la producción
mayor para la vida del país como por
ejemplo el paracetamol
una empresa de baterías para los autos
eléctricos va a abrir aquí en el norte y
va a traer grandes inversiones para la
transformación de la industria automóvil
el mes pasado lance un plan de siete mil
millones de euros para la investigación
para las empresas aquí en francia y
estamos desde hace dos años no sólo
somos desde hace dos años la primera
nación europea de lo digital entonces
vamos a continuar invirtiendo y
alentando estas iniciativas que han
creado más de 160.000 empleos estos
desafíos sin embargo que son los
nuestros es cambiar de escala
generalizar por todas partes a esta
dinámica volver de nuevo a ser una gran
nación de innovación de investigación de
agricultura y de industria
reindustrializar reconciliar el
crecimiento y la ecología de producción
a nivel nacional el descenso de los
impuestos de producción así como los
impuestos sobre las sociedades como lo
decidimos van a permitir acelerar este
proceso a nivel europeo la previa del
presidente francesa desde la unión
europea que comenzará en enero de 2022
nos permitirá construir una agenda
industrial y tecnológica después de las
consultas que se están llevando a cabo
decidiremos de un plan de inversión con
un solo objetivo construir y francia de
2030 y hacer lo que emerge en nuestro
país y en europa los campeones de la
industria biotecnología de la
agricultura o de lo digital y eso va a
decidir nuestro futuro la segunda
convicción es que tenemos
hemos visto la fuerza de nuestro modelo
social que ha protegido nuestra cultura
de nuestros empleos nuestras empresas en
muchos sectores frágiles así como
también ha protegido los niveles de
gastos de los franceses y esto se basa
en uno
y pilar que es el trabajo sin trabajo y
sin producción no hay financiación de
nuestra salud no hay financiación de los
servicios de desempleo ni tampoco de los
retiros entonces continuaremos desde así
con ese principio que es el trabajo y el
mérito es por eso que vamos a continuar
invirtiendo en la formación a lo largo
de la vida vamos a formar
y más personas que solicitan empleo y le
he pedido al gobierno que a partir de
septiembre lance un plan masivo de
recalificación de las personas que no
tienen empleo por eso
se llevará a cabo la reforma del seguro
de desempleo desde el mes de octubre
debemos siempre poder ganar la vida
quedándose en casa
o trabajando y siempre he tenido un
lenguaje de verdad si nuestro sistema es
injusto con 42 regímenes distintos
mantiene desigualdades mayores y
tendremos que avanzar hacia una mayor
simplicidad para que haya más justicia
los regímenes especiales tendrán que ser
suprimidos para los nuevos empleados de
esos sectores sí porque vivimos más
tiempo tendremos que trabajar más tiempo
y irnos al retiro o más tarde no será
mañana o de manera uniforme o brutal
porque hay que tomar en cuenta la
dificultad de los trabajos y de las
profesiones pero crear un sistema que
cree la minuta las diferencias según
como se trabaje la salida al retiro
tendrá que ser más tarde y los retiros
para una carrera completa será superior
a mil euros por mes en términos claros y
simples para proteger estos estás
pensiones sin aumentar los impuestos es
justo
y eficaz cambiar nuestro sistema de
pensiones
he escuchado los debates en el momento
hay que hacer esta reforma desde el mes
de julio y no sería después entonces si
le pido al gobierno de jong castex que
trabaje con los socios
para trabajar en este tema no voy a
lanzar esta reforma hasta que la
epidemia no esté controlada y la retoma
económica asegurada mi tercera
convicción es que la nación le debe una
respuesta a todos aquellos que hayan
sido golpeados fuertemente por esta
epidemia sobre todo a la juventud que ha
arriesgado todo a los más viejos que nos
preocupamos por sus vidas por las por
los jóvenes tenemos que continuar
haciendo inversiones en la educación de
los menores y ésta sigue siendo nuestra
prioridad para salir de esta crisis para
los jóvenes adultos
los estudiantes los jóvenes activos o
aquellos que han sido poco formados
hemos creado una plataforma un joven una
solución y vamos a continuar con este
programa que ha permitido que 2 millones
de jóvenes con obtengan a veces un
empleo o una formación imaginen eso
526.000 contratos de aprendizaje en 2020
lo que es un récord origen y para
amplificar esta dinámica voy a presentar
muy pronto una garantía universal para
los jóvenes muchos se han enfrentado a
una soledad
y les debemos una solución humanista
para la autonomía y unas casas de retiro
modernas
apoyar a los jóvenes y también los
viejos es un nuevo pacto entre
generaciones que tenemos que construir
como nación esta ambición tendrá que ser
financiada y no será por un aumento de
impuestos y aquí también me mantengo
constante con la supresión de él
el impuesto de habitación y también del
impuesto de los ingresos lo que
representa a 170 euros de más para una
persona con el salario mínimo hemos
asumido mejorar el poder adquisitivo de
las personas y no vamos a dar marcha
atrás no vamos a financiar esto 'no
aumentar las deudas de las próximas
naciones ya tienen que enfrentarse a la
deuda climática y no le voy a agregar a
esto la deuda financiera el único la
única manera de asegurar este pacto es
trabajar para y no innovar inventar
invertir y mejorar nuestro crecimiento y
continuar reformando el estado como ya
comenzamos a hacerlo con la reforma de
la alta función pública y la supresión
de elena simplificar en todas partes
donde sea posible la acción pública la
única solución es continuar cambiando el
sistema y las posiciones establecidas
las rentas los estatutos
y es así que vamos a retomar el control
de nuestro destino como nación es así
que vamos a retomar todos el control de
nuestras vidas como ciudadanos la
voluntad de que francia que pensé debe
llevar es bien esta retomar el control
de nuestros destinos garantizarle a cada
uno de nosotros que pueda retomar su
destino profesional personal familiar y
cívico muchas preguntas tendrán que
encontrar encontrar respuestas en los
próximos meses y aquí no tengo las
respuestas en este momento en este
discurso
he escuchado las preocupaciones que hace
sufrir las violencias que sufren las
mujeres particularmente en las parejas y
la falta de respeto hacia las fuerzas de
seguridad y las fuerzas del orden
escuchado
también lo que se vio con la gran
abstención en las elecciones regionales
y departamentales y tengo en mente el
tema del equilibrio de nuestras
democracias pero sin embargo tengo sus
actitudes
tenemos que prolongar nuestros esfuerzos
y no renovarlo inventando de nuevo un
nuevo modelo que nuestro país y el mundo
esperan las cosas en el mundo están
cambiando también gracias a iniciativas
que están siendo propuestas por francia
ahora que recordar que fue en estos
primeros días del estado del verano 2021
donde apoyamos un impuesto global del 15
por ciento de los grandes impuestos
poniéndole fin a los paraísos fiscales
francia estuvo en primera línea y logró
hacer que el mundo y europa se movieran
queridos compatriotas este verano de
reencuentros que será hecho de momentos
familiares ya mí que les será también un
verano de lucha contra el virus y de
vacunación y de cuidado tengo confianza
en ustedes confianza en nosotros para
mantenernos unidos serenos y
determinados entonces al regreso
tendremos una cita con nuestro futuro
para construir una francia independiente
que no viva en la nostalgia sino que
se para tomar las decisiones necesarias
para su destino una francia que
conquista y que tenga confianza en la
fuerza de su juventud una francia unida
que sea también solidaria cívica
responsable
y que viva la república y viva francia